My connection to the sea started when I was little I spent
most of my summers at the sea. Swimming, snorkelling…
Ever since I was two and a half years old, I started swimming, I kept on developing love for the water
The water here in Moraska is different from anywhere else here in Slovenia
As a Slovenian I feel like water is part of my DNA
the part of the country where I am from is surrounded by
lakes and rivers and waterfalls and
there is something so healing about water. I love, I love the sound of it
it kind of puts me into a meditative place.
Despite being so small Slovenia really holds high biodiversity
but also diversity of geomorphological forms and also types of water,
we have these lively Alpine rivers flowing down the mountains and meeting
the sea, the Adriatic Sea, and bringing in nutrients, minerals
that support high-productivity and diversity.
This place is special because it’s like a perfect union of man and nature
very contemplative and good for humans and animal and plants living here.
You would not think at first sight but also the mud here is good for us
putting it on, feeling how it works on the skin, it’s amazing.
In the same way as the landscape, the land, and the waters change along the Slovenian coast,
so 5 mins from place to place the mud can be completely different.
Lake Bohinj is really special, it’s the biggest permanent lake in Slovenia
and it’s also a lot quieter than the other lakes which makes it that much nicer to be in.
What makes me most happy though, is that this beautiful nature is only
one hour away from our very busy city, Ljubljana, so that makes it extra special.
One of the things I love the most is how I can fill my water bottle up
whether there is tap water or going by the mountain where there is the water source.
Water in Slovenia tastes different wherever you go and one such a area is Rogaska
where water is full of magnesium and it’s very beneficial for your health.
In Slovenia we have two waters which are very special because
they are mineral drinking waters,
all other waters are thermal mineral waters which are used for the Balneo therapies
but here the Balneo therapy means drinking.
Donat Ng mineral water has been attracting people here for centuries
because it is the mineral water with the highest content of magnesium, no other water
in the world has more than 1000, to be exact 1040 milligrams, of magnesium in 1 litre.
The black mineral water comes from deep underground in Zara Mulabasin,
They call it black gold because of a high concentration
of healing substances and it has beneficial effects on health.
I prescribe patients a program:
In the morning patients might have bathing in water
and in the afternoon they can have a mud treatment.
One of my favourite places to escape to is a very magical natural pool surrounded
by beautiful waterfalls, but I am not going to tell you exactly where that is,
you're going to have to come and discover it yourself.